on va plus loin avec notre invité
philippe chalmin bonjour et merci de
répondre à france 24 vous êtes
professeur d'histoire économique à
l'université paris dauphine on voudrait
notamment une brève histoire économique
d'un long xxème siècle 1913 2018 d'une
mondialisation à l'autre c'est paru aux
éditions jacques bourrin
gazprom donc sanctionne la pologne et la
bulgarie pour ne pas avoir payé les
importations en roubles ne sont pourtant
pas les seuls alors pourquoi eux
ben parce que à la limite ce sont deux
pays qui ont probablement pris les
positions anti russes les plus
virulentes ça n'a rien d'étonnant de la
part des polonais on connaît le vieux
contentieux qui règne à entre la russie
et la pologne et la pollock d'autre part
comme vous l'avez dit l'ordre dans votre
reportage la pologne s'était déjà
préparée d'abord il faut rappeler que la
pologne n'a pas coupé son charbon et
reste le pays européens dont la
production d'électricité et la puce
liées au charbon la pologne un avantage
aussi d'être riveraines de la baltique
la norvège les palois vous l'avez
entendu la pologne par ailleurs peut
apporter du gaz naturel liquéfié donc la
pologne et les pays baltes savez très
bien que il risquait gros continuent à
dépendre du gaz russe la question
bulgare est beaucoup plus sensible parce
que en bulgarie les élections de l'année
dernière ont amené au pouvoir un
gouvernement très pro européens alors
que
jusque là la bulgarie avait maintenu des
relations
relativement
favorable à la russie est donc à quelque
part il me semble que la stratégie russe
est d'identifier finalement les maillons
faibles est incontestablement la
bulgarie est probablement le pays le
plus dépendant et géographiquement le
plus difficile à approvisionner en gaz
en provenance d'autres sources si ce
n'est qu' il faudra que d'une manière ou
d'une autre l'union européenne face à ce
niveau la preuve de solidarité on va en
parler mais est ce que il y à d'autres
pays qui sont aussi dépendants du gaz
russe ont parlé de l'allemagne et de
l'italie est ce que ces deux pays sont
dans le viseur de moscou est ce que ça
peut aller crescendo
je pense que moscou à ce niveau-là à une
stratégie des petits pas vous me direz
que en matière guerrière hills avait
fait ça avec le dombass avant de lancer
l'invasion de l'ukraine coupées
à côté stablement le pays le plus
dépendant est de loin celle allemagne
puisque grossièrement si je prends
l'année dernière sur les 150 milliards
de mètres cubes que l'union européenne a
importé en gaz de russie il y en avait
45 pour l'allemagne est un peu plus une
vingtaine pour l'italie est le problème
de l' allemagne s et qu' elle ne dispose
pas de capacités de regazéification ce
qu'il faut bien le comprendre c'est
qu'il ya deux manière d'acheter du gaz
soit vous achetez du gaz gazeux et à ce
moment-là celui-là circulent par des
tuyaux et forcément ses tuyaux peuvent
passer un peu sous la mer mais soudée
mer relativement limité la belgique la
méditerranée entre l'algérie et l'italie
etc mais ça va pas très très loin soit
vous importez ce qu'on appelle du gaz
naturel liquéfié qui donc du gaz naturel
qui a été liquéfié qui est transporté à
moins 160 degrés dans des méthaniers
qu'elle arrive et il faut les capacités
de regazéification et sa l'allemagne
n'en a pas et dont quatre pour quelles
raisons pour quelles raisons c'est c'est
dû à l'héritage de mes requêtes ça
non c'est même du ha
globalement à la philosophie allemande
qui a été dans sa transition énergétique
l'allemagne a une position très claire
dans sa transition énergétique
nous mettons tout sur le renouvelable
nous ne voulons plus du nucléaire et
nous acceptons d'abandonner le charbon
le problème du renouvelable c'est qu'il
est intermittent ça n'est pas un
problème nous allons avoir du gaz russes
et les allemands sont tannés même encore
plus loin vis-à-vis des russes lorsque
les russes leur ont dit que vous savez
ça nous embête un peu d'avoir des tuyaux
qui passe par des pays pas très
sympathiques comme l'ukraine ou la
pologne qu'à cela ne tienne on va vous
construire un tuyau qui va passer sous
la baltique le fameux lors nord stream 2
oui
il ya nord stream et nord stream a
continué à fonctionner nord stream de
lui nous ferons cela ne fonctionne pas
n'a jamais fonctionné mais il est
construit il est construit mais donc
quelque part c'est toute la transition
énergétique allemande qui s'est fait
avec une dépendance totale ou gaz russe
ce qui explique aujourd'hui que le
chancelier olaf scholz il bloque des
quatre fers toute idée de mettre enfin
en barre haut
pour le gaz et même pour le pétrole les
produits p les raffineries de l'est il
faut pas oublier une chose l'allemagne
de l'ouest elle a hérité l'allemagne de
l'ouest et l'allemagne de l'est
elles étaient totalement perdus rss et
donc les raffineries par exemple
d'allemagne de l'est elle fonctionne
avec du pétrole russe alors je vous
laisse répondre au téléphone
on parle on parle et de la solidarité on
parlait de la solidarité européenne et
cette dépendance donc qui touche
certains pays est plus que d'autres ont
parlé de l'allemagne et de l'italie
la commission propose un plan qui vise à
réduire de deux tiers les livraisons de
gaz russe d'ici à la fin de l'année est
ce que ça vous paraît atteignable en
sachant que l'europe entière absorbe 40
% de ses besoins en gaz russe
d oui le problème c'est le tiers restant
est est ce que les russes
accepteront de perdre deux tiers de leur
marché ce qu'il faut bien se rendre
compte que c'est un piège à double
détente et autant les russes peuvent
exporter leur pétrole ailleurs autant
ils peuvent pas exporter leur gaz si
l'export les 150 milliards de mètres
cubes que la russie a exporté l'année
dernière sur l'union européenne et ses
imaginons que nous réduisions des deux
tiers nos importations donc ça enlève
100 milliards de mètres cubes les russes
où est-ce qu'ils vont le leur capacité
de tuyaux pour sortir izon un gazoduc
qui part vers la chine le gazoduc
orgueil de sibérie mais il est déjà
quasiment saturés et donc quelque part
et les russes ne remplaceront pas le
débouchés européens
donc c'est un peu un petit jeu dans
lequel on se tient par là bas par la
barbichette et je ne suis pas sûr que
les russes irons et feront le le pas
suivant qui serait de couper les
approvisionnements
de gaz vers
l'allemagne ou l'italie ce d'autant plus
que le prétexte qu'ils aient donné le
coût des paiements aux bleus ça a été
parfaitement expliquée par votre
journaliste bon ossébi d'accord sur une
solution qui permet à personne de perdre
la face à ce qu'il est que pour les
acheteurs continuent à payer en euros ou
en dollars il le paie sur un compte de
la gazprombank ici l'agacement banque
qui fait le change en roubles et qui
règle à soi voilà gazprom en roubles 1
être entre nous c'est de l'hypocrisie
mentale
et donc on aurait pu continuer à avoir
ce système avec la pologne et la
bulgarie mais la pologne la bulgarie
sont identifiés comme deux opposants
l'épaule né sont vécues comme un pou ce
crime par les russes et les bulgares bah
c'est quand même un maillon faible dans
une zone des balkans à côté de la
hongrie qui elle sans aucun problème le
kabar à durban a bien entendu accepté de
régler en roubles et n'a aucun problème
une dernière question est ce que vous
pouvez me répondre par oui ou par non
est-ce que ça augure une nouvelle hausse
des prix de l'énergie
c'est mon jeu non je vous dirai
peut-être traque les prix du gaz sont
déjà est élevé je tâte simplement que
hier enfin on n'a pas encore peut-être
totalement et on reste à 90 mégawatts
c'est à dire on reste à des niveaux qui
je le rappelle sont sept à huit fois
plus élevé que le prix du gaz avant la
crise en 2018 2019 ça il faut le
rappeler est donc de toute manière ça
veut dire que les prix du gaz restent
ils historiquement élevé aujourd'hui le
gaz naturel il vaut deux fois plus cher
que le pétrole merci beaucoup c'est
passionnant philippe chalmin de nous
avoir répondu en direct sur france 24 je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'histoire économique à l'université
paris dauphine là